I'm speaking to mr peach who were work
to the city hope bridge. Public works
approaches. This is tape too we were
just talking about the metropolitan
rowing construction and hyde park.
Yes i can well recall the huge holes
that were dug in hyde park. Both northern
and southern meaning and again over and
when you park for women sation. Mostly
by day labor and with very little
mechanical of very little
mechanical help. I can well recall.
Particularly on the hyde park side or
a dry the horses dry yes we used to
carry away this has been excavated
. From the station and it would
go down. It was taken down
live or straight to the bottom of the little
falls freed and dreams of the head of
darling harbour and now
provides us the the good siding
a space for the good side at darley home
so good. Do you remember on the north side
as well that the ceremonies they had
starting the bridge on the north side and no
sydney station. No i did i could i was
on the some sign my point was this that
dr bradfield was being i suppose with with
his ministers approval in fact ministers
. Connived shall we say he didn't have
a contract or any surety that the
bridge would be started in yet they had
a public ceremony whereby the bridge was
started before the contract had been let
go. I don't recall anything on
that at all. No this butler was
there as well i didn't see anybody else
from the office did you know her yet.
Talked about your secretary.
She was rather one of my
strata down there but she was quite
a lot. She was right. Your brother butler
sister. Yes tried to make the sister and
she had charge of the typing and what it
now. We know was the typing bureau and
wanted to try chris and an office on the
other side of talked about hurdles. My
name my nose. Yes
a lot of people have questioned her
position but in actual fact she was this
confidential secretary wasn't she. Yes
yes. She mattox you and i were seized with
one of the groups when jeanette
who went across i did not. He
was overseas with
a group of engineers from his
staff to examine. Possible
tenderers for the construction of
a harbor bridge and. Was
still back in sydney
and has in documentaries was
she became aware. Now that's
a good way to put together she
became aware that there was
a moon when i went on the idea of
calling dr bradfield and his staff
and putting
a stop to any further work on
the. On the development of the
bridge itself. They were going to send
him the cable on tell him she were
fortunately knew exactly where dr
bradfield was that time so completely
horrible ition. She said dr.
Brent feel the cable and suggesting he
should be somewhere else for that particular
style i never caught up with him. I
wondered i documented if you see. Because
i don't know what i did the research. I
knew something that happened because he
said he had not received the cable
and i thought well he's not
a man to lie and he said he didn't receive
the cable that he didn't receive the
cable but i was awfully
sure that there was
a nelson trick in here somewhere and you
just. Just filled it in for. What happened
was the government changed of course and
it was indeed they were indeed thinking of
dropping the bridge and the reason for
this because the government came in was
a coalition with a country
party wasn't called
a country party then it was the country
party and they particularly broke and was
leader leading the party at that time and
they wanted the bridge dropped and it was
it was touch and go. Indeed it's very
interesting. He went at it. He didn't get.
No that's resonating. I wondered well how
that was worked. She was she she paid
a key position. She is to advise him what
was going on but that wasn't the point of
her job but the reason i understand it was
some jealousy of her position did you
ever hear that i was i understand there
was some jealousy of her position did you
ever hear anything about them. No i don't
think so. I don't know the jealousy would
. She was there
a long time before the british actually
started. Yes i was aware of that and of
course when the bridge actually started
she left and went and got married she
married and went to queensland and another
secretary took over but it was she who
was the current provided the confidential
link. While he was overseas and only she
knew everything that the tenderest because
he sent his report back and incidentally
out. I can't find
a copy of this report. Every
meeting that he had. He
risk got
a transcript typed out of the meeting was
taken shorthand of the transcripts were
typed out and they were sent back two copies
in two different lots of mail in case
anything happened and the one person who
provided that link at the other end was
miss butler and she had all the information
and he had all the information on all
the proper proposals of the tenderers so
that he knew exactly what their tenders
were going to be before he got them. But
a so only he and she and the personal
staff i believed stuckey mr stuckey and
a couple of others would know. Did you know
any of the confidential arrangements of
the likelihood of the tenders. Now i'd
know i don't think i did but i've got
a copy of that report. Is what i was aware
the point was that she was confidential
in that respect that she kept that instantly
i can't find either of the copies they
were to definitely definitely two copies
of this book which was for the minister's
eyes only. But here was two copies and i
can't find either the copies i know there
are and i've heard that there are and
but i can't find them. You'd have
a look at this one that i got to.
Well that feels really it was a quite
a long while after i got that i get tired
i think it. Don't quite or in what it was
when here afterwards. Now there is has
fascinating. Do you remember any other sort
of inside stories are there in the office
there. Not inside stories. I remember
the night i took raised.
We were we were. There.
He from time to time as the ridge was
proceeding he used to take well he would
arrange for parties taken
over the bridge. Dr.
Redfield would arrange doc
about feel with a room. Yes
a doctor about and it
to celia raines more or
less unofficially but and he relied
very lively on his staff to provide
the people who could to company who is
around on the show were told what was going
on and one afternoon. I've
been asked. I think it can
you. What are you doing tonight. How. I
said well and i think bruce and i got some
iranians really and they said well look he
said do you think is an each answer tour
coming as he was some professor or might
have been and chancellor of one of the
american universities here some pretty
is somebody or some considerable
significance and i said well
look our going out with
a rosy fix. He said all of our bringing
rose. I said you think it we all right.
Usages i have to talk to break. Just come
in all that will be right. So fair enough
. Rows and i met the party. Somewhere over
the north sydney you know. Well rosalynn
she was. Well i arrived pretty
you know very effective
a very hearty laugh. And the
party got off somewhere about
half way across the bridge of the right
level. Somebody in mark they couldn't see
the guest of honor. Must remember i saw her
back she was back with this chancellor
and then again he peels
a laugh from the other side of the room.
He's right and commandeered the prince.
Visited dr.
Bradfield of all staff.
This. He recalls he was
a v.i.p. But there was very embarrassed
particularly the following day. Nothing was
said. There's like goodwin
. Quite
a regular thing. A lot of people who are
interested in people of consequence. Oh i
remember the governor-general
and lieutenant governor. I have
a picture of them on top of the arch.
They were they went up just after it was
joined you know i know i don't recall and
but i remember gary that was his name
. Sir. Somebody yeah i think he must have
been the guy. He was i think he was the.
The. The governor-general at that time was
stunned of an lots donovan stonehaven. Yes.
That ought to be the governor-general i
remember seeing
a photograph on had he was very
well an english players and. I have
a feeling that might have been his time
there were so william cullen he was the
local deputy deputy
governor of course there's
a state governor but of course bradfield
would know him very well because he was
there also the chancellor of sydney university
at one stage. They were on the scene
and he was on the senate who did you have
a university education at all it did you
do you like quiet myself i don't know. For
some after be able to stay long enough
to go to graduate. Most of dr bradfield
staff were all. We're all graduates and
yet you yet you served your time. So to
speak. Yes i suppose you put it that way
so he wasn't i was under the impression
that he sort of deliberately picked everybody
who has graduates and if your odd man
out. I can ask well he picked
you as well yes in fact
to do
a personal job to all i can say is this and
this is not for the record but when the
national. Sydney harbor bridge
staff was selected. For the.
There was gordon stuckey.
Bill ice myself and roger
but we were there for original probably
work stuff all right. Avoidable.
Stuff and those i suppose we were
frankly. Oh yes i. He was he
was never in the office. There was
frankly roper there were several but
we all went to the war didn't say yes yes
it was light horsemen. What he didn't
know that he was like no he died
so yeah. Somebody tell you.
I haven't have now when they trying
to record it immediately died
a little while ago but he wrote
some some things about dr.
Bradfield for his daughter mary and she
has them. There were some interesting
little vignettes which he wrote
for her. Miss mary bradfield and
frankly she feels wife were
friends. Was that it. You
didn't know him very much. As an officer
queensland's and what not. Not personally
very much. Very well i would come in contact
with the only because he was outside.
We were inside most of the time. And what.
What about you were separate your branch
was your design of the approaches.
Yeah yeah i was really pushed
into that because i knew something about
the right way. Location system or so far
as he was concerned. And so you weren't
involved with the checking or the design of
the main bridge. No no that's
principally studies. And he had
a team with him as well. Oh yes yes. Where
did they work in relation to where your
team was you know we had we had practically
had most of the third floor in the
works department where we just went to one
of the one of the officers there. Where
did you live when you worked in
the workbook. You know. After
a long hard road here and you went to
work on the ferry naturally. Yes yes. You
member of the life around sydney in those
days. What did you do for recreation.
I saw tennis as you might see
a time in those days as travelling on
work and study. What hours of work you do
have though what hours of work. Did
you have oh i think we started
about nine of the morning
till half past four and now
a lunch. How many days five
days. This is. This is
officially but working work
time was pretty flexible as
days. And if you had to work late you didn't
get paid an extra for it not. Oh no no
no. I know that's why i
got that somehow assembly
. Yes
a doctor redfield well of course he was
working on schemes which he didn't really
turn into money either. He was doing it
for the for the thing he was doing it
through his interests but the other
ones that i was most aware of was the.
Only the milling transport
right or facilities is on
the law side of the highway here.
The story bridge and the us and
turning back of the irrigation of the
worst since western plains. That
i have come across a man who worked
in the same sort of thing for dr.
Bradfield when he was working on the story
bridge in queensland. And he is name was
snowden bill snowden
snowden. Enter it. He was
a young engineer and he worked in the drawing
office for on the design of the story
bridge in brisbane and he did the
approaches and he worked directly with dr
bradfield and dr bradfield also got him
to do other jobs and he went out and took
the levels for the inland water scheme.
Did he know i doubt now that actually he
said that one day when he'd been
working for dr bradfield on the st.
Lucie
a university and they were university
of queensland site. Plans which. He
spent
a bit of time on as an extra amount
of. A period of time and then one
day. Dr bradfield produced a small
map. He said which was probably
a shilling or two sixpenny map
of queensland on which was drawn
a number of schemes. And he said
to phil snowden. I want you
to take some levels on this and that's how
it started for him due to meredyth think
about that map of orlando. He went out
on foot and horseback and train and
every method and he took the levels for
those by know he was employed by dr.
Bradfield he was paid for it. You know i
wasn't he was given time off from the
bridge. You know he don't have the approach
as you say the bridge was already well
underway and his job was mainly done and
he the design office and here he asked
dr. Redfield asked for mr.
Holt who suggests old
if he could use him for
a while and so he was second to talk about
field doctor brett you're paid into that
. Well that's called some mine when we had
been transferred to mine. Rose and gone
out of order. I wasn't
terribly happy about my
nose for
a level that they weren't very nice people
to work or not engineering was in right
and. I was looking around to
get a job if i could somewhere other
than where we were and dr banfield wrote
a long letter pry offering me
a job up and britain with him to work
on the bridge bridge. And at that time.
Depression was as worst. Nobody
had a job if you had a job your
a terribly lucky. We were expecting
a family here. And i was very taken with
the idea but i thought gosh almighty. If i
go up there and i get a job for a week for
a year or two and then finishes
cypress. I might well be without
a job. It was sort of situation i was
looking forward to. So i unfortunately
wrote to dr and told him that i just couldn't
do it gave him the reasons why. Well
i think that was the last time i had
a direct contract because i
don't know where when dr.
Redfield i and i don't know why it was
that he passed away. And i know whether
it's fairly obvious he went on there.
He was on the brisbane bridge and then
afterwards he was he was very very keen
on the on the inland water scheme and he
started to put all his energies into that
but he didn't have the resources and the
queensland premier turned him down money
wise and i know where it is i don't even
look all. Knowing anything about
him die or whether he was
sick or whether it happened suddenly what
he did just finishing liars away in the.
In in those days you don't get
a lot of contact with people like them.
I never knew she'd. Build lush was he
so i don't know anyone you know. Yes well
that's but that's what he just became ill
. The family say that it was the continuous
travelling up and down to brisbane on
the trains and cold and what have you in
general. Cause he was over seventy already
. And he was still working flat out and
you know although james holt. Sir james
holt later he was in charge of the job as
far as than bradfield was overall there
and he didn't really have i suppose that
awful lot to do but he couldn't sort of
rest he had to go on as far as he was
concerned that was all small it was although
it was all
a sort of preparation for the big one. The
big one was the inland water scheme it
was the irrigation and population. Of the
centre of australia. That was the big one
for him he'd spent all these years.
Yes. On the bridges but that wasn't
a big one and one of dr.
Bradfield staff. Carol. Right carol. Got
exactly the same position
in the south wales. As.
James hold. Yes. We're doing and
in queensland he was director of
public works he was
very well liked. He was
a very very competent engineer. I don't
know never recognize i don't think i ever
did but he was i was a very close friend
of mine is she a good deal if you use
a long sentence together. But these are
past now but when he died but it was right
he was the only man on the staff
the time. The the. With the
moves the main roads and all everything
else that was going on the historic red for
the staff are starting
to disintegrate getting
a little bit. I'm so dissatisfied no
what and rose high up because we've been
married. We were being sent to the city
to the country. She and i got married and
a week or ten days notice it was just
like that. I rang rose i'm going to be
married friday. I said we've got because
i got to go to i got a i've got
a front up down and. Next monday week. And
there was as usual consolation but it
was alright. And right carol. Came on
soros and i hope all that's right now
for their i think
a really person from the whole of dr bradfield
staff or his previous staff that my
that trip. He was one of the resident
engineers for the public works approach is
always he actually supervising the approaches
on the north was he who is that right
now. He was approaching he was one of the
engineers on the approach he he did the
southern approach and arrive
a bit rival to the north side
was he supervising or already
a resident engineer or. I don't know
how you as i think you probably use
classified as
a supervising engineer but whether he did
or didn't live on the job he lived. You
know it. You know and talk
about feel was particular was
a meticulous about the separation of
jobs wasn't easy. You see on the harbour
bridge contracts there was the contract as
was responsible for the building of the
bridge they were also made responsible for
the design and that's where the argument
comes about right. They were made
responsible for the design. Dr.
Bethany all said that it was the he didn't
mean that he said he'd go to bed feels
that he didn't mean that they had to be
responsible for the design it was his
design. They had to be responsible for
the sufficiency of his days of his red
fields design but they
said bowen that's a that's
a whole other design but the point
was this that bradfield was was
particular that they would have responsibility
for superintending their job and
then there would be two resident engineers
one for the steel work and one for the
substructure that's frankly i feel for the
steel work and and roger butler for the
for the substructure for the bridge and
then on the approach is there would be
design engineer for the for the
approaches that was a list
a lush and then there would be two
supervising engineers who would actually
supervise the job of of the pro choose doing
the approaches and then there would be
two resident engineers also for the
approaches one for each side who are
responsible for supervising them. And that
would be separate and that is that that
is the thing that he did. Now which was
mr carroll was he was it was he was
supervising when i was either. The
resident engineer over him who was i think
engineer i would imagine. You were about
to say something and i cut you off.
I'm sorry about the design business. Who
designed what sort of thing is regarding
the bridge. When did i say that
a minute ago i was i got your train of
thought going on and i spoke about you spoke
about the. The start of the
work on north side. Was that
prior to all the the building of the city
railway or after it was well after the
city. I was well on the way when what i'd
done. I did the design for those time
also on the track where retaining walls all
that sort of thing before that started
and roper would be in charge of that work
at sydney. I mean we used to cross and
see him from time to time. Where roper
wasn't in charge of the work in no sydney in
the railway end of things. K
a phrase that was key phrase. Yes. I think
it was the actual during the period of
the construction of the bridge. Because
i know this separation of branches was
carried out carried out to
a certain extent you know keith fraser
who was the son of james frey's of the
railway commission at that time and
later case fraser himself became really
commissioner. I heard that there were some
antipathy between keyes fraser and dr
bradfield from
a number of people later. Do you ever hear
anything of this. No i don't and i don't
remember anything else that it could happen
when i wouldn't know about it. I also
heard that there were some antipathy
between a deejay forced who also became
a railway commissioner who was under
bradfield in the metropolitan area
construction foster that of them and of
course was before he was in the time of
leger and before boyd came to the the top
of the metropolitan really construction
branch. There was in the designing
principle designing engineer was a was
a teacher foster. And ledger was under him
and then was boyd and who was under and
there was somebody else under him. Who
that could be i have it on record. But
you have my not even name of
that site. I was still only
a cadet with the railway
department when i was with undid
a boy in the royal office. Do you remember
the propeller sorry. Do you remember the
prepare for asian of any plans for the
railways. There was before the public works
committee went
a number of proposals for railways.
Gordon to narrabeen and also
the railway to epping and all and on the
other side of the railway to east hills.
Now i don't know they were prepared
under poit i don't know whether he was
solely on the bridge end of things that i
was interested in finished we all know
remained somewhere from memory problems we
had dodgy all these you know how the the
headlands run down what are you going to
do. Did you go through them or do you get
around them or over them. Is what
you would have taken over the plan
that went right down to most men in two
branches wouldn't you wish. They were there
in ginal plan if the city railway in the
northern suburbs was one to two branches
one to go down to muslims and their one
to go down the manly. No no. The the one
that i did was the ones that run like ran
along the city road. And then came down
into manly into the army
only over and there was
a station under the roughly where
we grandstand now. I mean we are.
I think we i think we took advantage of the
slow ground that came right. Cool park
down through books while back down again
and then northward from there. Yes i've
seen that one too. Yes and the other one i
was talking about i didn't know whether
you know think about it. And later you
don't is the earlier proposal which dated
right back to nineteen ninety thirteen
nowhere and now i don't know.
Oh no. In fact he dates even further back
than that because in one thousand nine.
When there was a another
royal commission then under
a melbourne engineer named curnow. He
proposed tunnels in all directions and the
railway commissioners had plans for going
down to manly in all sorts of places you
know i don't remember what i'd only get
short pants. You know it was before
bradfield period even well no he was still
working on the designs but he got no
credit for them. Tell me again.
Re the city railway sorry
to harp on the police clearly you know
a lot more about the city railway. Do you
remember the problems of which you have
it down on the railway looking at the
construction construction of the city. I know
we'd left. I'd left by then but it
as it is now is very similar to
what it was intended to be well when i
was there. Do you remember those in the
inner city line which was to cut round. I
knew about it and it was built after and
joined in with the one that i know
would. That's more recent history you
know but the plans. I've got
a number of railway plans which were
during the bradfield there which must have
been during your area and the later one
in one thousand twenty six. Which shows.
The straight up the hill one you know when
he when they ditched the one in forty
for the one in thirty gauge and they went
straight up in the hill. Instead of going
in a loop. They also included
a inner city loop which cuts down and
part of it was actually made to remember.
It was some. Design where you
know where the rail i see
what is going east across across circular
quay and then it ducks in under that
headland that goes down towards under under
the conservatorium there was something
to do with the idea of branching off
inside that. From the inside. Now
the tunnel was built. It's it or the take
off. Is there still it was you. It was
proposed to be used as macarthur's headquarters
bunker during the second world war
. It was never actually used it's still
there. Exactly as it was i wasn't aware of
that they do what i mean that was used
during the war was very low as we
needed station at the very very low levels
when the national emergency services had
their headquarters. I was while
i was on the i was on i was
a departmental representative on that
conference. It was actually done. Do you know
any of the staff there who were in
that in that everybody i know was
a bloke called
a ranger. And i can show you the pass that
he signed to give me access to the place
my harry. Well i was listening
to a programme on the radio
a little while ago and broadband i think
it was on the baby sea radio. And somebody
was being interviewed and it was due this
right. It was judith wright the author
and poet. And she was on the staff of this
emergency section and apparently during
the during the days when the. Attack
by the midget submarines on sydney.